よろしくお願いします
ここで最初に皆さんに質問したいんです
けども
希望を持ってる人っていますか教えたら手
上げてもらいます
多くの方がまあそんなに手あげないので
結構みんなじゃあ絶望なのかなみたいな
そんな人たちのために今日僕の
夢希望を語っていい感じで帰ってもらい
たいと思います
けども僕の話って意外とつまらないので
それよりももっといい話ここ34年
めちゃくちゃ僕が集中してやった
ゼミのことについて
話していきたいと思います
まあ前の大学からここの大学に来た時に
まああの一生懸命全然やろうと思って
理系の学生でも大変な統計検定2級をゼミ
性全員に合格させるそれと
ゼミの甲子園と言われている一番日本で
レベルの高い
isfjで賞を取らせるで2つの目標を
掲げましたそれをまあいろんな知ってる人
たちに喋ったらまあまず
統計2級じゃなくて3級さえ合格させる
ことできないんじゃないか
ismjのショーなんて取れるわけない
じゃないか
なおかつまあ統計検定2級取ったり
isfjでショートのためには
週1回の税務所は絶対無理なのでそれ以外
に
集まってやるサブゼビっていうのやん
なきゃいけないんです
今の現在の学生でそんなわざわざサブゼミ
なんてやらないんじゃないかやらないん
じゃないかできないんじゃないかっていう
ふうに言われたんです
それをなんか
すごい僕言われて何でもできないできない
できないそう言われ続けた時に
ふと
自分の中学校の時思い出しました
小学校中学校ってまあ
僕が頭悪かったのか
勉強しなかったのかわからないんですけど
も高校受験に失敗して
東京の都立の一番下の高校に行きました
その時に
みんなに言われたのが中学校とか小学校の
友達に言われたのがなんて言われたかと
いうとお前そんなバカな高校行くんだもう
お前の人生終わりだろうみたいな大学なん
で行ける行ける行けるわけないじゃないか
みたいなそんなこと言われてまず彼らそこ
の高校に行ったことないのになんでそんな
無理だって言うんだろうみたいな
すごいなんか
僕自身なんかむしゃぐしゃしてきてじゃあ
そんなこと言うんだったら絶対大学行って
やろうと思ってまあ一生懸命そこで
受験勉強しました
その結果まあ無事に大学受かることができ
たんですけどもまあけどその代今すごい
一生懸命勉強しましたその結果は大学が
受かってちょっとした自信がつきました
それで
次なんですけども
僕の父親は大学の教授をやっていてよく
小さい頃小学校の頃によく父親の
海外で発表するので一緒に連れてって
もらって父親の
海外海外へのプレゼンテーションを聞いた
時に
父親の研究発表が
海外の人たちがもうスタンディング
オベーションするぐらいの光景をもう目に
見てたので
将来僕も海外で
勉強して
学位を取りたいっていうふうに思ってた
思いましたけど実際にアメリカに留学
するってことはすごい結構
度胸がいることなんです
まず
些細なこと一つなんですけども
僕あの
仙台の大学に行っていてその時一人暮らし
だったので水道料金日本語でさえ
水道料金をこう
交渉するのはすごい難しくてアメリカ行っ
て俺水道料金払えるのかなみたいなそう
いう不安があってなかなかそうアメリカの
大学院に留学するっていう気持ちが持てな
持てませんでしたそれをそういった僕を
なんでじゃあアメリカの大学院に行こうと
思ったのかそれも本当
些細なことなんですけど
仙台の大学に行っていて仙台では
有名な繁華街の国分町ってあるんですけど
もそこであの
夜な夜な
遊びに出て女の子を特快1回遊んでんじゃ
ないかみたいなことが
学校内で広まって
すごい欧米に対してのそのなんか
評判が良くなかったんですよその時に
たまたま付き合ってた
女の子今の妻なんですけども
すごい彼女はすごい優秀で
それでその指導教会がその噂を聞いて
彼女はすごい優秀でそのまま
研究者に行ける道だったんだけどもお前の
指導を辞めるか
岡島君を取るかどっちにしろって言われて
彼女はそれを
指導教科を止めて僕を取ってくれたんです
てことはつまり
僕は彼女の人生を台無しにしてしまったと
思ってしまってじゃあもし僕がアメリカに
行けば
彼女もアメリカの大学に行くんじゃないか
と思ってまあ一生懸命勉強始めますけど
実際に
国分町で余命な遊んでたのでもう英語の
学力もすごい低かったのでどうにかして
短期間で入学決めたいと思うんで5ヶ月か
なんとか留学をしたいと思ってたので一生
懸命英語勉強しました
それもどのように勉強したかっていうと
まあ朝3時に起きて
夜11時までそれを土日も休まず毎日やり
ましたその結果なかなか点数がまた上がら
ないんですよねそんな簡単にそれでも
ストレスから
帯状疱疹ができたり
自分のこう
ずっと座ってるもんだからズボン
後ろが全部破けるぐらいもうずっと全部
パンツが見えるぐらいあとずっと書いてる
からもう手が痛くて
鉛筆が逃げれないんですよそれどうやっ
たかっていうと
鉛筆を持って
手拭いで巻いて
勉強してました
それで最終的にやっと
本当に苦労してやっとアメリカの大学院
TOEFLですほぼ満点取って合格する
ことができましたその時やっぱりちょっと
自信つくんですよね
すぐやっぱ自分が努力したから
そしたらまた今度無事にアメリカの大学
行ったんだけど
すごいまた大変なことがあってなんでかっ
ていうとアメリカの大学院は世界で各部で
エリートが集まってくるのでなかなか
点数が伸びていかないです
点数が伸びていかないと何がまずいかと
いうと
最初の1年目でクラスメイトの
平均点以下の人は大学辞めなきゃいけない
んですだから何として僕は半分以上に行か
なきゃいけないけども
世界中のエリートが来てるからなかなか
なかなかずっと一生懸命勉強してもずっと
下の方
でこんだけ努力しても下の方っていうので
もう本当に毎日アメリカのキャンパス
大きいのでそこに川が流れていてそこに
橋があるんですけども本当毎日毎日
学校の帰りに橋の下で悔し涙を流したのが
今でも本当昨日のように覚えてます
それを何とか
頑張って頑張ってクラスメイトも助けも
あってなんとかその
平均より上に行って最終的に額に取れたん
ですけどやっぱそれもすごい
自信になるんですよ
そうすると何がいいかっていうと
始め僕まあ生まれた時めちゃくちゃ
ちっちゃいなおちょこなんですよ
それが一つ一つの受信がどんどんどんどん
大きな大きなおちょこに変わってくるん
ですよ
それは具体的に何かというとまず自分に
自信がつくので
自信持って人と話すことができる
自信持って人と話すことができるという
ことで何がいいかっていうと人がほぼ信頼
してくれるそうするとどんどんどんどん
いい人が集まっていくんです
それが1点目ともう1点目は何がいいかと
いうと
いろんなことやってるとめちゃくちゃ失敗
するんですよもうほぼ失敗だらけもう成功
したことなんて滅多になくて一生懸命やっ
てもめちゃくちゃ失敗するそうすると
めちゃくちゃ悲しい気持ちになるんだけど
それは何がいいかっていうと
他の人が失敗したらかけてあげる言葉が
わかるんですよだから本当の優しさを
身につけた感じがします
そういう経験を踏まえてじゃあ前線のため
に僕は
ゼミ性の人生を変えさせようそのために
統計検定2級とisfjを合格させよと
いうふうにここに使いました
けど実際にやってみてなかなか難しいん
ですよねまあ今までの大学だとハードルを
超えさせるような教育してなかったので
楽だったんだけども
実際になかなかハードル超えさせることが
できなくて本当に苦労してます
例えば統計限定2級なんですけどま
なかなか機嫌通りに受からせないで今は
試行錯誤やってる状況
もう一つすごい難しい問題があってそれが
自分たちに自信がないからちょっと何か
言われると
人を排除しようっていう風に前世はどうし
てもしてしまう2年生の最初の頃に
ちょっと他の人に意見が違うこと言われる
と自分のこと言われてると思ってその人が
排除してしまうとしてしまうそのことは
絶対に僕は辞めたかったのでまずゼミとし
て
自分の嫌がることは絶対にするなというの
と
異性に対して
絶対そういった
養子とかそういったことは絶対言うような
人の悪口は絶対返上で言えるというのを
徹底しました
それでどうなったかというと
実際初めみんな自粛の自信がないので
うまくいかないんですけども
徐々に徐々に統計検定2級受かったり
小さな大会で買ったりするとすごい自信が
ついてくるんですねこれ最終的な目標の
isfjのまあだいたい34ヶ月前には
やっぱすごい自分の自信が持ってるので
他人にどんなことが言われても集中して
愛する時代に取り組むことができる
それはまたなおかつすごいいいことは
自分にやっぱ自信持ってくると
銭入れとしてこうやった方がいいんじゃ
ないかっていうのを先輩後輩に
ちゃんと意見が言えるような学生になって
います
実際に
isfjで勝つってことはすごい
めちゃくちゃ大変なことでまあ
なんていうのかな
実際他の大学は
Excel
元のあったデータで分析したりするんです
けど
うちの大学はまあ
うちの大学っていうか僕のゼミは
勝ちたいのでどうやってるかというと
世界で
岡島ゼミしかないデータを
唯一作り上げてますその作り上げるのも
めちゃくちゃ大変でまあこれくらいある
紙ベースを全部手打ちで打ち込んでもう
本当に
世界貴重なデータセットを作り上げるそれ
なんで重要かっていうと
isfjで発表するときに
世界で1個しかないのでしかもそれが
すごい量のデータそうするとあの審査員の
方もすごい心象がかなり良くなるので
他の大学と違ったことを絶対にそれも
めちゃくちゃ大変な作業それは前世が一丸
となってやり遂げる多分もうその
やり遂げる学生って言って多分うちの全員
の学生しかいないと思うんですけどそれは
本当にすごい
誇りに思ってます
まあそんな中で
実際に
isngもすごい大変だし
統計検定に雪も大変だし
すごいまた僕からすごいプレッシャーが
もう毎日のように来る中でなんで前世
こんなにもうやめてもいいのになんでうち
のゼミでいるんだろうってすごい思いまし
た
ペットもこういう機会があったので
全店にみんなに一人一人何でうちのゼミで
頑張れるの
みたいに
聞きました
そしたら
みんな言ってたのが
まず
先生が希望を持ってくれてるから僕たちも
希望を持てるそれでこのゼミで言うと
自分たちが成長できると思うから絶対に
続けたいという風に言われましたまあ
ぶっちゃけそう言われてめちゃくちゃ
嬉しいですよねなんでかってそういう環境
を作るのが僕の役目だから
そういう環境を作るのが
やっぱり大人の役目なんですよ
本当にそう言われてめちゃくちゃ嬉しくて
それじゃあどういう学生が
具体的に希望を持ってたのかお話すとまあ
1期生17人いて2期生は10人3期生は
9人4期生は今6人いるんですけど
1人1人タイプの付き合いやってるので
一人一人ストーリーがあります
全部の話一人一人に話ししたいんだけど
もう時間が今5分42秒しかないので1人
だけ話すここで喋りますまあ1人彼の話な
んですけどまぁ最初に全然説明会で
犬の一番に来てくれました
それでうちのゼミは夏休み2年生の夏休み
に統計件で3級を受かるのが乗り場なんだ
けど
彼は2級を
真っ先にその時期に合格しましたそれで
まあ夏から大会出るんですけどまあ
他の前線も一生懸命やってすごい善人の中
で一生懸命やっていろんな大会出てました
けど彼は元から理系
志望だったのであの理系の大学に
他のところに移りたいというふうに思って
たらしくてそれまぁゼミでやってるので
彼らが起こした行動っていうのはゼミ製
全員納得してもらうように自分の気持ちを
伝えました
了解を得てから彼は僕に行って
僕も彼がそう言ってるそういう道に行き
たいんだったらもうそれ
僕させても嬉しいのでじゃあその道に
目指しないよっていう風にしました
それでも僕たちまあ
統計検定2級目指したりisfj目指して
いるのでなかなかまあ
彼が一生懸命その編入試験頑張ってまし
てるんですけどまあちょっと
連絡できなくなってそれでまあある日一つ
でまあ編入試験まあもうすごい頭が良かっ
たのは絶対怒ると思ってたんだけどもう
落ちたっていう連絡があって
それでまあ他のゼミ性が連絡しようとした
んだけどなかなか連絡が取れないけど
ちょっと僕たちはやっぱりisfjがある
ので
仕方なくどんどんどんどん
進めてきましたそしたら
isfjの
本番1ヶ月前にある一人の税制が連絡取れ
て
カウンセラーと彼と僕で3人で会うことに
なって
実際にそこで彼が言ったのはもうその生き
ていく希望がなくなったみたいにすごい
言われて
僕としてはやっぱその
is頑張った間彼にちょっと連絡取って
なかったので僕の指導がすごい不十分だな
めちゃくちゃ後悔して
その時に彼カウンセラーと話し合った後に
研究室に来て
彼と話した時に
ゼミ性も僕も
彼のことすごい気にしてんのになんで
そんなことするんだ
僕もさ心理学の
知識がなかったのでつい彼に言ってしまい
ましたそしたら彼は
随分その気持ちはわかるんだけど
スイッチが入ってしまうともうどうしても
できないという風に言われます
その時僕は思ったのはじゃあスイッチ入れ
なきゃいいんだそういう気持ちにさせ
なきゃいいんだと思って何をさせたかと
いうと彼めちゃくちゃ勉強好きなので
例えばちょっと彼の
家は母子家庭でお母さんがよく働けって
言って勉強できない環境にあったところ
まあわざわざ布団に入って一人で勉強して
たりするような子だったのでもう研究をさ
せようisfjに一緒に取り組もうと思い
ましたそれで2チームあったんですけども
片っぽのチームに入れてそれで彼すごい
その
結果すごい彼集中して
片方のチームのすごい歯車が間してなんと
そのisjと同じぐらいのレベルの高い
ウエストで
上位3位に入りました
上位3位って多分本当にすごいことでまあ
本当
有名
確たる有名大学と同じレベルまで彼
引き上げだけじゃなくて他の人もやったん
だけど
引き上げてくれて何が良かったかというと
彼はその後
理系のあのすごい難関の国立大学に合格
することができましたあの大学院
それで彼その大学院の面接で
うちのゼミでやったことを話した時に
すごいその指導教科の人からすごい評価さ
れてもう彼は今そこで一生懸命勉強するっ
ていう風な夢を
持
って
実際にここで
本当に気づいたんですけど
統計検定3級受からないとかISSA
受からないとか言ってる人は
希望さえ持ってないんですよそういう大人
の人はけどもし
僕が
彼らを信じて
本当に真摯に向かえばもう彼らは途方も
なく成長していくんですよね
それが本当に重要で
本当にそういった環境を大人が作って
あげるそれが唯一のハードルを超えるやり
方だと僕は思ってます
それで最後にまあ最初に
僕が
言った僕の夢なんですけどもやっぱり父親
と同じでやっぱり自分の発表をアメリカの
学会で発表したいそれでスタンディング
オベーションをやっぱ貰いたいとすごい
思ってます
その中のスタンディングオベースに
ゼミ性がいて触れたらいいなっていうのは
僕の夢です
以上で
発表があります
[拍手]